[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video were coming to be discussing
the infamous Grindelwald or more
specifically his 8 most powerful spells
and abilities we first see grown the
world on screen and fantastic beasts and
where to find them which premiered in
two years later he showed up on our
screens once again with fantastic beasts
the crimes of Grindelwald Grindelwald is
the dark wizard of his time preceding
Voldemort as the quintessential dark
presence in the world intent on
challenging all notions of light and
embracing all aspects of darkness he is
widely considered by many to be the
second most powerful Dark Wizard of all
time second to only Voldemort though the
notion that his second - Valda mode is
challenged by some who believe that
Grindelwald is the ultimate force of
darkness anyway we'll save that
discussion for another video
Grindelwald was born in the year 1883
and in his younger years he was a
student at durmstrang Institute while
attending the school Grindelwald
demonstrated exceptional magical ability
however his sadistic nature also shown
through and he was expelled for
experimenting with twisted and dark
magic after being expelled Grindelwald
was intent on achieving higher and
higher levels of power this mission for
power eventually landed him in Godric's
Hollow England Grindelwald initially
travelled to Godric's Hollow because it
was where igniters peril the first owner
of the cloak of invisibility
had been laid to rest he thought that
Godric's Hollow could be a good start in
his ultimate goal of achieving immense
of was of power fortunately for him his
aunt Matilda Bagshot the author of
history of magic happened to live in
Godric's Hollow this gave him a place to
stay during his time there it was during
this time that Grindelwald first met
Albus Dumbledore a man who had become
massively important and influential in
renewals life the two were inseparable
and they both happen to have
of an innate ability to perform magic at
an extremely high level during the time
that they spent together the two were
able to learn a lot from one another
reaching new heights with regards to
magical ability they had a lot in common
each as ambitious as the other not only
that but both boys shared a common goal
to seek out and acquire all three of the
deathly hallows the cloak the wand and
the stone they were under the impression
that if they acquired all three that
they would become both immortal and
invincible with the power that came from
the Hallows the boys would subsequently
lead a Wizarding revolution that would
effectively put an end to the
International statute of secrecy
breaking down the secretive divided
between muggle and magical worlds this
revolution would create a global power
hierarchy that would place powerful
witches and wizards at the top of the
food chain effectively giving them full
control of muggles and muggle Affairs
when Dumbledore's brother had before
learned of what the two boys are up to
he openly expressed his disgust for the
plan this would eventually lead to a
considerable amount of tension between
Grindelwald Albus and Aberforth
Grindelwald at his boiling point used
the Cruciatus curse on a before and at
this point Alba stepped in to defend his
brother at the end of the three-way duel
between the Wizards Alice's sister
Ariana was killed in the crossfire this
effectively put an end to the
relationship between Grindelwald and
Dumbledore and the two parted ways after
parting ways with Dumbledore Grindelwald
stole the elder one from Riku Gourevitch
who held the one at that time with this
wand Grindelwald power reached new
heights as did his following operating
under the slogan for the greater good
Grindelwald and his acolytes were
responsible for attacks all across
europe what made Grindelwald so
dangerous was his ability to
effortlessly conjure magic that other
Wizards couldn't even dream of producing
the film's so far have just given us a
taste of what he's capable of so for the
rest of this video I'm going to be
discussing his top eight most powerful
spells and abilities or at least the
ones that we know about so far I'm sure
that as the film
released we will see more and more
insane magic from him particularly as we
are yet to witness the fabled duel
between Dumbledore and Grindelwald which
eventually brings an end to Grindelwald
reign of power number 8 the Cruciatus
curse the Cruciatus curse AKA crucio is
a classic curse used by many powerful
dark witches and wizards it's a favorite
of Bellatrix Lestrange and one of the
unforgivable curses when cast crucio
inflicts excruciating pain on the victim
pain so excruciating that is considered
to be torturous casting crucio is to
require a wand and incantation and its
effects are said to vary depending on
the casters desires and emotions to
produce the excruciating pain implied by
the name the caster must despise the
victim and enjoy causing pain Harry
Potter
after coucher was cast on him described
as feeling like his head was being split
open while having his bones set on fire
Grindelwald most notably used this curse
on Albus Dumbledore's brother app' for
inciting the three-way duel that would
end Grenda Ward's friendship with Albus
number 7 Transfiguration like Dumbledore
Grindelwald is a master of
Transfiguration which is defined as the
art of changing the form or appearance
of an object or person Transfiguration
is a particularly complex branch of
magic that can go quite wrong if
performed incorrectly
there are several branches of
Transfiguration most notably
cross-species Transfiguration and human
Transfiguration Grindelwald most notable
accomplishment in the field of
Transfiguration thus far was when he was
able to transform himself into Percival
graves for an extended period of time
seemingly having no need for any sort of
Polyjuice potion which is what Barty
Crouch jr. used to sustain his form of
Alastor Moody Grindelwald also
impressively transformed the reins of
his incarceration carriage into snakes
yikes number 6 healing magic the
efficacy of Grindelwald healing
abilities may be partially tied to his
possession of the Elder Wand
however he was already notably
proficient
forming healing charms in the fantastic
beasts film Grindelwald effortlessly
heals the cuts and credence bare-bones
hands both oneness Li and non-verbally I
can't even begin to imagine what sorts
of healing functions he is capable of
when truly applying himself number 5
invisibility just like Albus Dumbledore
Grindelwald was able to cast a
disillusionment charm at such a high
level that he was able to make himself
all objects take on the exact colors and
textures of different environments much
like a chameleon
this results in you basically being
invisible negating any requirement for
something like an invisibility cloak
Grindelwald proficiency at casting this
charm meant that the invisibility cloak
was the deathly hallow that he was least
interested in number 4 tempest jinx in
one scene in fantastic beasts we see who
we think is Grindelwald locked up in
incarceration carriage being escorted by
various auras the man locked up in the
carriage is actually a transfigured
Hanafi it is during the scene that
Grindelwald casts The Tempest jinx The
Tempest jinx is an atmospheric jinx that
causes bolts of lightning to emerge from
the clouds striking your targets this is
an incredibly powerful spell and just
another example of Grindelwald elemental
mastery number three the lightning bolt
curse when Grindelwald jewels were more
like toys with Newt Scamander
and fantastic beasts at one point he
conjures some sort of blue lightning
spell the blue shock waves emitted by
the spell knocked Newt Scamander to the
floor and then it looked as though Newt
was being tortured
it actually seems sort of similar to the
Cruciatus curse perhaps this is
Grindelwald own version it's unknown if
this spell is lethal or not however
knowing Grindelwald bit more than likely
is number two white elemental blast
though we don't know the exact name of
this spell at one point in fantastic
beasts we see Grindelwald produce a
white blast with this one white fiery
blast Grindelwald is able to
successfully incinerate five auras
effortlessly I'm curious if we will see
this spell again as it is clearly
extremely powerful and seemingly easy to
cast and lastly number one protego
diabolica the spell you've probably been
waiting for protego diabolica is
potentially the most powerful spell any
of us have ever witnessed across all
harry potter and fantastic beast films
it makes a very Kedavra
look like a Kea we first see Grindelwald
using protego diabolica in the Lestrange
mausoleum
protego diabolica is a dark spell that
creates a ring of protective black fire
around the target anyone who is an enemy
of the caster will be instantly
incinerated when they try to enter the
circle
however allies should be fine to enter
it unharmed
though I'm not sure that I'd want to
test it the possibilities of this spell
seem endless as this is not just a
static circle of flames we see
Grindelwald controlling the spell like a
weapon extending tendrils of black
flames towards his enemies with these
tendrils Grindelwald was able to prevent
auras from escaping the mausoleum via
apparition the spell eventually
escalates into what can only be
described as a fiery winged demon
similar to fiend fire it's mentioned
that if the spell hadn't been stopped by
the combined efforts of the protagonists
that it would have destroyed all of
Paris this seems to outclass Avada
Kedavra by just a little one thing worth
mentioning is that the spell is black
but in the film adaptation is blue so
that it's more visible and that's it for
this video as I said before I'm
interested to see developments with
Grindelwald magical Arsenal as the
film's progress did I miss any of his
major spells I know that he has more
abilities I just wanted to mention the
top eight until next time you're a
wizard Harry
[Music]